[Musique]
tu veux faire quoi
plus tard alors cette question nous
l'avons tous entendue parce que tous les
parents du monde
la pause à leurs enfants les grands
parents les oncles les tantes et même
les amis la famille et nous sommes
certains que vous aussi de temps à autre
vous la poser aux ados de votre
entourage
alors faisons un petit exercice
remontons le temps un instant nous avons
saison
souvenez vous la pleine adolescence on
vous laisse deviner qui est qui
et oui ce sont les photos que vos amis
prennent un certain plaisir à ressortir
pour leurs discours de votre mariage
non les a quand même projeté parce que
en la voyant on s'est dit que de temps
en temps ça fait du bien de sentir qu'on
a vieilli
alors voilà remontons le temps vous avez
16 ans vous avez à peu près cette tête
là on a les dossiers donc posez vous la
question que vouliez-vous faire à cet
âge là pour certains c'était très clair
comme l'évocation vétérinaire
astronautes footballeur musicienne
présidente de la république
pour beaucoup c'était plus nébuleux ça
dépend des jours et surtout qui fait
aujourd'hui ce qu'il pensait faire à
saison alors on peut se mettre d'accord
sur un point ce n'est pas une question
facile
comment on fait pour y répondre
en fait on pense souvent que c'est le
fruit de notre personnalité profonde que
nos envies sont le résultat de nos
expériences de nos rencontres de nos
lectures de notre imagination
en fait on a le sentiment d'avoir choisi
librement
c'est vrai mais pas seulement les rêves
qu'une croyance d'avoir choisi sont
aussi le produit notre environnement
ce constat n'a rien de neuf les
aspirations des enfants sont fortement
conditionnés par les familles dans
lesquelles ils naissent ainsi avec une
mention bien
vous serez beaucoup moins nombreux à
vous orienter vers une filière d'études
d'excellence
si vous êtes issus de milieux populaires
al'inverse avec cette même mention bien
vous serez deux fois plus nombreux à
vous orienter vers une filière d'études
courte
alors on vous leur fait parce que c'est
quand même un truc de dingue
vous étudiez dans un lycée agitée en
classe vos copains vous traite de
bouffon ou d'intello parce que vous avez
plutôt des bons résultats
vous rentrez chez vous et le soir va
vous dormez dans la même chambre que
votre frère qui est lui aussi un peu
jt et en plus vous vous occupez de la
paperasse administrative à la maison
bref vous vous démenez pour obtenir un
super bac dans des conditions vous êtes
moins favorisés que d'autres et le
résultat c'est que vous allez vous
autoriser des études moins ambitieuse
que ceux qui ont eu les mêmes résultats
en étant plus favorisés et c'est ainsi
qu'en france
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes né de
parents faiblement diplômés vous avez
quatre fois moins de chance de suivre
des études supérieures à votre tour
le pire c'est que ce n'est pas une
fatalité en matière d'égalité des
chances
la france est dans la queue du peloton
des pays développés donc cette question
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard
elle est redoutable
elle était peut-être redoutable pour
vous peut-être aujourd'hui pour certains
de vos enfants pour les nôtres mais pour
les jeunes issus de milieux populaires
elle est encore plus difficile parce que
leur environnement conditionnent leur
avenir alors nous depuis 15 ans nous
nous sommes mobilisés pour l'égalité des
chances parce que ça nous est
insupportable de voir à quel point votre
naissance conditionne toute votre vie
future
alors on a beaucoup lu on a beaucoup
écouté les jeunes leurs parents leurs
enseignants et on s'est peu à peu changé
notre conviction pour répondre à cette
question redoutable
il faut travailler dans trois directions
savoir vouloir pouvoir savoir parce
qu'il s'agit évidemment d'avoir accès à
une information fiable mais comment
fait-on quand on ne connaît pas les
filières de l'enseignement supérieur
quand on ne sait pas par où commencer
et quand on n'a pas grand monde autour
de nous susceptible de nous renseigner
vous voir parce qu'il s'agit de se
projeter dans l'avenir et la motivation
est donc fondamental et c'est là que
peuvent surgir les barrières mentales
qui freine beaucoup de jeunes et en
particulier les jeunes issus de milieux
populaires c'est ce qu'on appelle vous
en avez entendu parler
l'autocensure le pouvoir parce qu'il
s'agit d'être en mesure bien sûr de
suivre les études et de faire les
métiers que vous enviez
j et là il faut bien se connaître
il faut être réaliste sans se surestimer
messieurs sans se sous-estimer medan
alors savoir vouloir pouvoir
c'était vrai quand vous étiez ado ça
reste vrai aujourd'hui sauf que l'ado
d'aujourd'hui n'est plus l'ado que vous
étiez il est aujourd'hui connectés et
ils passent beaucoup de temps sur les
différents écrans qui sont à la maison
sept heures par jour pour être exact
notamment pendant les repas de famille
et ses deux heures de plus pour les
jeunes issus de milieux défavorisés
donc notre ado est connecté partout tout
le temps ça nous vaut un certain nombre
de discussions dans le cadre familial
mais qu'est ce que ça change
bon disons le tout de suite on a pas que
des bonnes nouvelles
ça va faire un peu discours de papa
flipper mais rassurez vous ça va bien se
finir
alors commençons par le savoir le web
c'est vrai c'est une extraordinaire
promesses de démocratisation du savoir
tout est là à portée de doigts tous les
métiers possibles et imaginables du
monde toutes les formations dans tous
les pays du monde
rien qu'en france quand vous tapez
orientation études supérieures sur
internet
vous allez voir émerger plus de 55
millions d'occurrences alors comment on
fait à 16 ans pour s'y retrouver dans
cet océan d'informations
évidemment on peut demander un peu des
deux parents mais surtout on va sur le
web où on se laisse gentiment guidée sur
le réseau nous avons des amis qui nous
facilitent la vie les fameux algorithme
est subtilement ils peuvent nous
conseiller nous orienter voire même
avoir tendance à décider un peu à notre
place
comment est bien en s'appuyant sur vos
traces numériques votre historique de
recherche vous localisation notre mode
de consommation donc notre revenu vos
préférences culturelles et sites ainsi
que les algorithmes risque de reproduire
sur internet
toutes les ségrégations économique
social culturel territorial qui s'opère
dans la vraie vie
progressivement s'organise autour de
vous comme une bulle algorithmique qui
conditionne votre accès au savoir
alors le savoir il est bien là au bout
de vos doigts mais si on se laisse trop
guidés par les algorithmes et bien pour
la découverte pour la mobilité sociale
ce n'est pas forcément gagné alors après
ce vertige du savoir le second risque
c'est la distraction du vouloir vous le
savez sur internet il y a une une guerre
une guerre économique avec un enjeu qui
est de capter votre attention
sa porte même un nom c'est une science
c'est la catho logis en gros c'est de la
psychologie comportementale ou on
analyse toutes vos petites faiblesses
tous les ressorts qui vont permettre de
capter votre attention et de vous
retenir et c'est très efficace
combien de fois vous êtes vous laisser
embarquer beaucoup plus longtemps que
vous ne le pensiez on commence à
regarder une série puis une autre puis
une troisième puis encore une autre
et combien de fois vous êtes vous
retrouvée sur le web à faire finalement
absolument autre chose que ce que vous
étiez venu chercher au départ et cette
science de la distraction est
particulièrement efficace pour les
adolescents pour eux encore plus que
pour nous il est difficile de renoncer à
une satisfaction immédiate au profit
d'un engagement de long terme
c'est ainsi leur volonté leur capacité à
se projeter qui est fragilisée ils
deviennent progressivement prisonniers
du temps court et de l'instant après le
savoir après le vouloir en quoi le
numérique peut-il altérer notre pouvoir
internet c'est un endroit où on se met
en scène et parfois on triche on peut
avoir une deux trois voire plus identité
on va soigneusement choisir les photos
que l'on présente sur nos profils
facebook instagram etc etc bref il peut
y avoir une confusion entre la réalité
de ce que l'on est
est ce que l'on présente aux autres le
pouvoir sur internet c'est aussi cette
capacité à manier l'illusion
a présenté une version optimisée voir
fantasmes et de nous mêmes alors pour
des jeunes ados qui ont déjà deux trois
trucs en ne pas forcément très simple à
gérer
c'est évidemment une tentation
ça peut être rassurant mais c'est aussi
un risque parce qu'il se retrouve assez
vite confronté à une avalanche de
profils flatteur ils y participent aussi
d'ailleurs et cela peut nourrir la
comparaison voir altéré l'image qu'ils
ont d'eux mêmes et avec les jeux vidéos
en réseau
c'est encore plus fort un jour je me
suis rendu compte que mon fils avait
dépensé tout son argent de poche sur le
jeu vidéo
forsythe et lee qu'est ce que tu as
acheté avec ton argent de poche
papa c'est juste des skinheads atos
ok alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas forcément et bien les skins ce sont
des avatars ses personnages très stylé
mais les danses papa regarde sans trop
top et ans et là il me montre son avatar
son skin qui commence à effectuer une
petite danse trop stylé devant d'autres
d'amateurs qui se mettent eux aussi à
danser
alors moi jusqu'à just dance j'avais à
peu près suivi mais là donc voilà
comment on peut se retrouver avec un
lego digital très malléable qui vous
donne des capacités magiques mais qui en
réalité peu vous fragilisez parce que
plus vous avez de pouvoir dans le monde
virtuel plus il devient difficile de
construire son estime de soi et d'avoir
envie de se confronter avec le réel
et cette magie du virtuel est une menace
pour tous mais les jeunes sunnites
populaire - prévenu des risques souvent
moins encadrées sont plus vulnérables
alors comment fait on pour se défendre
dans cette économie qui conditionne
notre accès aux savoirs qui distrait
notre vouloir et qu il nous entretient
l'illusion de pouvoir virtuel alors là
vous vous dites ras-le-bol 1 on n'est
pas venu intel x pourrait coûter 2 réac
nous débiner internet
rassurez-vous si on souligne ses risques
c'est parce qu'on est convaincu nous
aussi qu'internet est une promesse pour
le désenclavement l'émancipation
l'affirmation de soi ça peut être un
levier fantastique pour l'égalité des
chances
sauf qu'il faut que nous les artisans de
l'égalité des chances mais nous nous en
parlions des outils du web
donc il faut que nous aussi on se met à
utiliser la puissance des réseaux
sociaux que l'on construise nos
algorithmes que l'on s'appuie sur les
neurosciences
alors pas pour vendre de la publicité
ciblée en fonction de vos données
individuelles mais bien pour mettre le
numérique au service de tous donc nous
sommes retroussé les manches et nous
avons conduit ensemble la plus grande
expérimentation en matière d'égalité des
chances et d'orientation qui a concerné
à ce jour plus de 150 mille lycéens et
oui on s'est rendu compte qu'à 16 ans
les difficile de répondre à la question
tu veux faire quoi plus tard par un
métier on ne connaît pas ils auront
sûrement changer d'ici une quinzaine
d'années c'est une question quand même
très angoissante et puis on l'a bien vu
pas forcément très utile parce qu on
fait rarement ce à quoi en penser à 16
ans et oui il faut être humble
l'orientation c'est le pouce ou jean une
série de décisions graduelle alors on ne
leur parle pas de métier lointain on
leur propose des projections immédiate
des filières d'études qui comporte des
matières qu'ils aiment
aujourd'hui ou qui s'en approche il
s'est ainsi pas à pas qu'on entre sa
motivation son vouloir donc les oncles
les tantes les parents les amis de la
famille quand on pose cette question tu
veux faire quoi plus tard si on ne vous
répond pas par un métier ce n'est pas
très grave ne soyez pas trop impatients
et ne mettez pas la barre trop
tout de suite pour eux mais comment
faire pour choisir parmi les quatorze
mille piste d'études supérieures si on
ne sait même pas ce qu'on aime
aujourd'hui comment leur construire un
parcours d'exploration des possibles est
bien avec les algorithmes mais les
algorithmes qui vont les aider à
découvrir et non à reproduire
prenons un exemple concret vous êtes un
lycéen de bon niveau à dominante
littéraire vous êtes à saint denis
vous êtes à cambremer en normandie notre
algorithme va vous permettre d'avoir à
explorer exactement les mêmes pistes que
le bon lycéens littéraire d'un lycée de
centre ville parisiens qui lui a eu
toutes les informations
grâce à son entourage qui connaît très
bien toutes les arcanes du système
et oui c'est ainsi que malgré les écarts
sociaux territoriaux à profit illégal
c'est à dire à pouvoir égal nous leur
donnons un égal accès aux savoirs et ça
marche
la moitié des lycéens que nous avons
accompagné ont choisi une piste d'étude
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas ou
n'envisagez pas auparavant
alors quand ils ont exploré
quand ils ont vu des pistes d'étude qui
correspondent à leur potentiel et à
leurs aspirations
comment fait-on pour les invités à s'y
projeter comment actifs dont leur
vouloir ou trouve rarement sa voix de
façon rationnelle
suite à une longue introspection n'ont
fondamentalement on fait des choix parce
qu'on a envie de ressembler à des
personnes qui nous inspire sauf qu'il
faut sortir du fantasme
donc on ne s'appuie pas sur les
célébrités en tous genres qui encombrent
le web on s'appuie sur un réseau
d'étudiants bénévoles que l'on réunit
dans un réseau social dédié à
l'orientation donc finalement nous aussi
nous utilisons la capte au logis pour
attirer les ados puisque nous nous
fondons sur leur envie d'être ensemble
en communauté en tribu et aussi sur le
fait qu'ils font beaucoup plus confiance
à des jeunes qu'à des adultes
et c'est ainsi qu'après avoir choisi des
pistes d'étude
nous mettons les lycéens en relation
avec
étudiants qui sont eux mêmes engagés
dans ces pistes d'étude et qui leur
ressemble vous l'attendiez que ce
produit
l'étincelle l'étincelle de l'inspiration
pour qu'elle fonctionne il faut de la
distance bien sûr on n'est pas inspiré
par quelqu'un qui lui ressemblerait trop
il faut pas trop de distance non plus
vous n'êtes inspiré quand on entrevoit
en l'autre impossible enviable qui nous
entraîne
quand vous êtes en contact direct avec
des étudiants qui étaient à votre place
il y a quelques années qui viennent à
peu près des mêmes lycées qui ont à peu
près les mêmes notes et qui se poser les
mêmes questions que vous sauf que
maintenant ils ont quelques éléments de
réponse évidemment en tant que lycéen
vous êtes super attentif neuf lycéens
sur dix déclarent avoir plus confiance
dans leur projet d'orientation
c'est énorme et s'il sein d'algorithmes
et fraternelle cette fraternité active
aujourd'hui c'est quinze mille étudiants
bénévoles qui nous montre que l' envie
d'aider l'envi de s'engager
elle est là très présent donc appuyons
nous sur cette énergie et sur le digital
pour construire l'égalité des chances
2.0 avec beaucoup plus d'impact et à
nous de mobiliser la jeunesse sur le web
dans le réel pour que l'autre ne soit
plus source de distraction source de
frustration mais bien source
d'inspiration et ainsi les aider à
prendre le pouvoir sur leur avenir
merci
[Applaudissements]